penser que n'importe quoi que nous
tomber dessus jamal juste avant la
première de scènes de la vie conjugale
de représentant quatre sous je vous
écoute est en coulisses par les queens
dans le chenal hier nous avons entendu
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre tête à
membres qui monte sur scène et faire
face au public
j'ai dit à evelyne hier parce qu'on se
parle beaucoup je sais pas si c'est ça
que vous avez entendu mais je lui disais
tu sais il y aura peut-être des erreurs
ce soit il y aura peut-être on va
peut-être but et on va peut-être se
coupe et on va peut-être dérangé par des
choses dans la salle on va avoir des
réactions imprévues et même si il ya
plein de petites erreurs ça compte pour
rien parce que la seule chose qui tombe
c'est c'est ce qu'on a travaillé et ce
désir qu'ont à de faire vivre cette
chose pour la partager
pour que les gens là reçoivent après ça
que ce soit parfait parfait ya toujours
des erreurs
j'ai pas vu des rares j'ai beaucoup aimé
je vous rassure mais cet ex au sein des
vies conjugales
ça parle le problème de coupe c'est
écrit en 72 73 par bergman est ce que
c'est un texte qui est toujours actuelle
parce que c'est assez violent
yu hwan qui dit qu'il disparaît il
abandonne femme et enfants est ce que
c'est un texte anti féministe en quelque
sorte
moi j'aime penser que même s'il ya des
relents peut-être un peu des années 70
des couples comme ça j'en connais il y
en a au tour parce que les rapports de
pouvoir dans un couple sont là l'égalité
n'existe pas à mon avis dans un couple
bien sûr on perd dans une relation
égalitaire des côtes etc
mais on n'est jamais tout à fait la même
place c'est des vases communicants ça
bouge
il y en a un qui ont un peu le dessus
qui prend le lead en bon français pour
certaines choses il y en a toujours un
qui a plus besoin qui est un peu plus en
manque
ça aussi ça bouge à l'intérieur de la
vie d'un couple donc c'est ce couple qui
est au départ peut-être un peu
dans une distribution des rôles qui est
plus traditionnel on va dire c'est quand
même l'histoire d'un affranchissement
celui d'une femme
comment ça vous concerne vous êtes le
couple plus podalire de l'univers tout
au long de votre carrière vous êtes
intéressé aux couples france à la série
rumeurs vous incarniez un journaliste
sportif une petite difficulté dans sa
relation avec une rédactrice en chef
quels souvenirs gardez-vous de cette
époque là la rumeur ça a été une
expérience extraordinaire parce que ça a
été encore une fois une sorte de ces des
choses qui arrivent pour toujours une
sorte de magie en que les textes qui
étaient brillantissime d'isabelle
langlois qui était plein de verve
d'humour répartie on n'avait plus vu ça
au québec ce genre de comédie aussi
incisive
vous avez revu certains épisodes de
berlin qui repasse des fois sur des
chaînes
il repasse un épisode ou ou un petit
bout puis je regarde un petit peu puis
faire quand même
quand même il était formidable tous ces
acteurs c'est ce que je me dis
j'ai plusieurs noms pour engraisser
david même afin que sa rivale acheter
malgré le temps qui passe à ce que les
gens vous arrête pour parler d'eux par
exemple de trauma ou d'autres
personnages que vous avez joué au petit
écran
déjà parent de tous et très drôle aussi
je vois pas ce que je vois vraiment pas
le lien entre les antilles m'a rappelé
en outre aux yeux on parle d'un clip
avec blanchet bruno blanchet sur son
émission n'allumez pas votre sécheuse je
pense quelque chose comme ça sur un sol
sous marin qui est devenue virale sur
les payes jeunes qui ont 10 16 17 18 ans
il me parle de ça d'autres vont de
parler d'autre chose
je ne peux jazzmen comme un
professionnel
ben moi je vous parlais d'une capsule
dans les beaubourg mais vite fait bien
rire dans les quatre comédiens ou été
visité par ses amis après une première
et qui se veut dire des choses pour
l'instant très gentils ils se
positionnent des meilleurs acteurs de sa
génération main sans pour autant dans
l'express est ce que vous lisez les
critiques pas toujours pas toujours les
critiques
alors là je vais me faire taper dessus
mais il y en a beaucoup moins parce que
vous savez que les en général les pages
culturelles des médias ont tendance à
s'atrophier alors c'est difficile pour
un jeune de 18 19 ans à 20 ans à
l'université aujourd'hui de rêver de
devenir un critique parce que c'est un
métier qui s'apprend faut être formé
vous étudiez il faut voir beaucoup de
spectacle pour avoir beaucoup d'heures
de vol avant de pouvoir devenir un bon
critique mais on vit dans un monde
aujourd'hui à montréal où tout ce qui
pourrait avoir cette ambition là
on pas beaucoup de gens pour les
soutenir et je pense que les artistes
sont les premiers à en souffrir c'est
dommage
james allemand merci mais il faut merci
facebook merci plaisir
[Applaudissements]